hello everyone I think it's time and we
can start so hello everyone and I
welcome you all to the free workshop and
we have been asked or by informatics for
next-generation sequencing so 2020 is
the second year of MIT university
Kolkata and Pine biotech collaboration
in the past one year we learned and
researched via several interactions you
started with own logic transcriptomics
program in 2019 March and then
introduction to by informatics program
it started in July and then the omics
logic data science program in September
we also started for group projects with
different faculty and several students
and we all did it with ease
we saw students who started with
absolutely no knowledge of
bioinformatics and NGS technology
perform their own experiment and scored
thousands of points during this meeting
I will introduce you all to our campus
ambassadors from MIT University Kolkata
who also talk about their experience and
to all our new participants and
interested students by informatics for
next-generation sequencing is a hybrid
training program on bioinformatics
launched in collaboration between MIT
University Kolkata and Pine biotech the
program is designed for students faculty
and researchers who are interested in
learning about data-driven research in
life sciences the program will start on
the 13th of January and online sessions
will be recorded and emailed to the
participant
okay so this will be an interactive
session we will be answering you via
chat so you can always ask your
questions in the chat box and also you
can unmute yourself and ask me a
question if you if you have any
confusion about anything that we go
through
so as I was saying the program will
start on January and run till March and
will be focused on data science skills
and machine learning method in
application to the analysis our
next-generation sequencing data in this
three-month course we will discuss
various aspects of next-generation
sequencing data generation and how this
field of by informatics has evolved to
handle such big biomedical data but
before we go and talk about the program
itself
I would like to ask you like why do we
want to learn about NGS data now or why
do I want you all to learn about the NGS
data well let's look at the history a
little bit like this year twenty twenty
marks seventy years you know since the
discovery of structure and function of
DNA molecules so from 1950 it took
almost 50 years to sequence the first
human genome what do you mean by what do
I mean by you know the human genome
project is that that was the time when
we started to look into our own genomes
the all the base pairs that we have so
we sequenced all the all the base pairs
three billion base pairs 3.2 billion
base pairs am i audible to other people
bicha can you confirm am i audible I
think on who is having some problem in
listening to the lecture Thank You
shanton okay so
please check your audio and try to
increase the volume okay so I was saying
that this Human Genome Project about the
human genome project so the human genome
project when it was done when it was
done we we went through you know
understanding what is composed of all
what is there in our own genome we were
trying to look at the genes they are
trying to look at and understand the you
know coding regions and the exons and
introns the whole entire genome so after
investing so much time and almost three
billion dollars we were able to sequence
our own genome and after that a company
called Illumina came in and they they
they started to you know evolved with in
the technology that helps us to generate
high sequence this high-throughput
sequencing so the technology evolved
rapidly during this time and in 2015 we
have 1000 genome project that brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community so
you see that from that period of 1952
the period of you know in 1990 we
gradually understood about individual
genes about individual proteins and then
the technology was available came and we
have a comparative model as the Human
Genome Project was done successfully and
then the technology evolved rapidly and
now we have thousands of genome that
happened in 2015 and in 2018 we have had
almost 100 thousand genomes sequenced so
today there is an ever increasing number
of genomics transcriptomics proteomics
and metabolomics datasets that are
available and which they describe the
subcellular processes with highly
detailed digital data for me it's a gold
mine because right now we have 600
sequences of almost we have million
of sequences from different organisms
humans in particularly have been studied
in so much depth because of things you
know because of the industry getting
involved in it because it's application
in healthcare so I believe that omics
technology has a huge role to play in
our healthcare in the coming days as I
was saying that omics technology and
next-generation sequencing how it plays
an important role in understanding what
we are trying to you know understand
about our own physiology about the
disease about the environment etc so if
I give you an example of genomics or
maybe if I talk about the clinical
features you know like how tall you are
what is your age and then its relation
to your state of health you know when
you go to a doctor he will ask that the
doctor will ask you about your age about
your you know why it's those things and
then relate you know medication
according to that so like in genomics
are in multi-omics or enormous like how
cancer affects the cell what is that
change which has caused such a deadly
event you know such questions can be
answered or can be better understood
through next-generation sequencing NGS
technologies are used to explore the
roles
relationships and actions of various
types of molecules that makes up the
cell of an organism many types of omics
data can be generated using in the NGS
as I already mentioned or what is also
known as high-throughput sequencing it's
both the same the data can show detailed
information about genomic variants like
you see in this example like you see if
you will be able to read every code
there so you can understand when you
compare that with from a disease State
or the number the snps the variation you
try to understand those relationships
and relate it with the you know
phenotype similarly epigenetics
regulations are playing so
critical rules in in today's world as we
are learning more and more about
epigenetic regulation methylation and
all those analysis can be done using
next-generation sequencing data in this
program we will be discussing about
transcriptomic data a lot so what is
transcriptomics data we are looking at
genes and their expression yes looking
at the expression of the genes in
different states and comparing that what
can be a person who has has who have a
cancer of a type and what will be an
expression of you know proteins in a
person who does not have you know who is
a normal person so we will be looking at
Gene's and also font expression
so for the program our first meeting
will be on the 13th that is on Monday
and it will be an introductory and an
interactive meeting with the participant
like we are doing in the zoo meeting we
will will be doing another zoom meeting
on Monday at the same time and we'll be
discussing you know we'll be discussing
that program we will be discussing how
to use the concepts that we did create
that we that we just discussed so we
will introduce you to the part you know
we will introduce you to the omics logic
resources the educational materials you
will have access to the a2 dot T dot T
by n for platforms we will help you with
your login credentials for our
analytical platform also which has more
than 30 scientific pipelines comprises
of hundreds of algorithms so I will also
show you and demonstrate you the
educational and we will also go through
the educational portal and also the T by
n fo platform which is the analytical
platform in this meeting we will just we
will guide you to use your house and you
use your profile
how can you score points and on
certificates through of the course while
learning about the NGS data and
application of machine learning so as I
was telling you to give you an overview
this program will leverage online
materials we offer for free which you
can sample to get a sense of the content
so we have several online material on
our educational site which just beeps
are shared with you all in the chat box
so here we have we have different forces
however in this program this program
will offer greater details and a full
you know and more focus on practical
application we will provide you guidance
and community support for your learning
as an example we will start with
transcriptomics one we will which we
introductory course for next generation
sequencing data analysis to study RNA
expression let me show you how the
online courses are structured so when
you go to when you go to the page you
will see something like this by
membership but as you already are a
participant of this program or you will
be a participant of this program this
will be provided free to you
and every course has this here you can
say this button take the course when
once you take the course you will see
each course has an overview video of
course topic overview which is under ten
minutes so in ten minutes you will get
to understand about what this course is
all about and then
you will have an online experience user
by going through this course I will
describe you how it looks within so if
you see the online learning experience
is designed to track user activity which
I mean what I mean is that we will be
able to see and you will also be able to
see and evaluate your own activity like
sheer there is a profile which has
points which which we can see I mean
we'll be describing more in detail in in
the number in the coming slides but to
give you an you know
overview we will have a each course has
a control section on the top where you
will find your profile link points to
your activity and displays we send not
if notification you can see the you can
see recent notification and your profile
link on the orange section of the
control bar here you will find find
addition additional button like you know
course outline search go to next lesson
image magnification download lesson PDF
change font size so it's an interactive
way to you know go through the lesson
and as you see here this is the first
you know tutorial of the force
transcriptomics one we start from the
very basic we understand that everyone
here comes from a different level some
of us does not understand biology so
much some of us does not understand data
analysis so much so we start from the
very basic from the DNA to the RNA to
the protein so that everyone can start
from very basic and build from there to
data analysis so we all are on the same
page right so these courses are built
like that
every courses and view during this whole
you know program we will have
assignments practical assignments so
these practical assignments will help
you to practice and learn more
assignments as time but they have a
longer you know complexion timeframe our
completion timeframe and they are school
so they they will be including practical
bioinformatics analysis using the server
T - bio info so our server platform this
is why it is important to have two
logins for each users and account for
the educational process and another one
for the analysis platform which is the
server platform the course itself we
explain the steps and you will be asked
to perform demo analysis in the
assignments we will try to run the full
pipeline and try to understand our
output so we will be using the server
platform which is this T by n 40 - by n
4 platform which already saw him and so
home has shared HTTP slash slash server
dot e - bio dot input but this will be
available exclusively to the
participants because it's a server
platform which which will be given
access to which has a five terabyte of
space which can be you know used for
your own analysis
so I will pause here for a minute and I
will wait if you have any questions and
then we can move to the next next class
okay so on the second class on January
16 we will do the analysis of gene
expression data with practical sessions
and online tutorials in this session we
will have theory followed by hands-on
session on building a demo pipeline and
understanding the steps of analysis
anyone with a basic knowledge of cell
and molecular biology will be able to
conceptually understand as well as
practically apply standard data analysis
tools to process analyze and interpret
complex transcriptomics data so we will
make sure in this session we will be
learning about you know data analysis
building a pipeline and it will be
really interesting because many of you
will be learning it for the first time
that how these complex algorithms can be
used very simply using a point-and-click
point-and-click platform where you will
be able to understand the data analysis
process and also understand that
research behind it so as I was saying
that
you will understand things in greater
detail once you go through these courses
these courses are like ebooks these
tutorials will guide you to understand
transcriptomics data analysis these
resources provide a broad and yet
detailed overview of processing
statistical analysis machine learning
tools and many other techniques the
courses cover methods expand on various
terminologies and practical examples and
as well as quizzes for your
self-evaluation so the benefit of
joining a program is that you get proper
guidance to learn about comics
technology you get regular online
webinars you get practical exercises and
we also provide support via our social
media platforms like whatsapp Facebook
Linkedin and we also have a forum where
you can you can you know post your
questions and we'll be happy to answer
you so as I was saying that about a
person who is registered with us how
will that person will be benefited so
every participant will have a personal
dashboard where they will see their own
progress they will score points and they
will get international certification
upon completion of each you know each
course as well as the entire program so
you get a International certificate
certification with for finishing the
program and doing a bioinformatics
project for one month so here I mean as
I already said that we have already
participants from a previous program who
have done excellent and still working
with us on various research problems so
one of such candidates or one of such
participant is Sarah Sarah Abraham and I
will like to give her the stage now to
talk about her experience with us and
how she has leveraged the educational
and the server platform
I will stop the sharing and I'll let
started to share her spoon screen hi
Sarah are you there hi Sarah I think
you're not audible to me
are you picture is sadder audible or
funny okay so I think Leah can you take
over and try to you know yeah okay I
will take over sure Sarah if you can
stop the screen cheering I think there's
some issue with the internet yeah okay
yeah thank you move it so I'll be
quickly sharing with you all and walking
you through the agile platform and all
the resources that you will get here so
let me share my screen so can you all
see my screen right now move if you can
just let it yes okay thank you everybody
so this is the educational portal let's
move it was talking to you all about
which is the ED you dot T - bio dot info
so this is a profile or the educational
portal that you come to the first time
and I'm going to quickly take you
through it and all of the things that
you will get
a lot of taps a lot of things that is
going on here and for a lot of new
people who are here at our platform it
becomes kind of you know overwhelming
sometimes going around where to find the
courses I just take your through so I'm
already logged in so as you can see you
can log out and log in to my own profile
and after logging in I can get these
tabs so the first tabs is the courses so
here you have all of these courses that
are listed down now most of these
courses are available for free but there
are also other courses on the platform
which are paid courses and there are
some courses which has a few parts of it
paid and some of it are free so you can
continue to go ahead and explore for
anyone who is starting for the first
time with biometrics or doing a program
for the first time it's always advisable
to start with introduction to mine for
my Tech's it gives you an overview of
everything that is there and you know
all of the courses as move hip has
already showed you it's very easy you
know you have a lot of text you have a
lot of video content and you can hover
over things that you do not know and
there are the Africans that is available
for you to study and then there are
reference links that you can go through
and you can explore this and we have a
specialization section and here we have
the even section so right now as you can
see we are having three upcoming events
which is like the almost logic
transcriptomics we also had a free
webinar yesterday on the upcoming
program so omnilogic transcriptomics
will start next week from 14 january
then we have the Amity program which you
all might be a part of and this webinar
is also part of that program and then we
have the LB RN program which is
transcriptomics program again but it is
by the Louisiana biomedical research
Network and with whom we have a standing
collaboration and it's going to be at
the Louisiana State University where as
two
can take this graduate session course
and earn points after they finish it and
their teachers will be taking the
classes so moving on you have projects
now this is something for anyone who is
new again on the platform you do not
have to go ahead and start doing a
project there are a few projects which
are free like this project but there are
others which are paid once so during the
session of this course whenever you have
you know whenever you learn about all of
the topics that we'll be covering in the
next three months we will be suggesting
some projects to you but again you can
also go ahead and develop your own
projects and you know we will help you
to work on them then you have these
other sections the about us the FAQ is a
blog and contact and if you go down
there is a lot of information here that
will help you to learn better how the
platform is to be used then you have the
courses which already dr. move it showed
you and if you go right down you will
have the testimonial section then you
have all the collaborators that we are
working with right now so you have Amity
University here and you have the
University of Haifa Loyola the LSU and a
toggle by informatics research center
from there our server platform the T bio
info where this symbol the t the logo
stands for chopper biometrics Research
Institute and Tulane University
University of Nebraska Medical Center
and so on so if you go down you have
very important links that are given here
but I'm going to talk about three very
important links right now the
organization activity and leaderboard
and the rest you are free to explore on
your own and you will get more
information about all the different
things that are there so you are part of
anyone who is taking part in this event
the biometrics for next generation
sequencing will be part of this
organization page so once you become a
member you can go ahead to this page
you can explore the different things so
the first thing is the information about
the program then if you go down you can
see all the upcoming events in the
program so here you can see that we will
be starting on 13 January then if you
click here you can see that it's next
it's going to be 16 January then we have
28 January and so on if you go ahead you
can see each of the courses or the
sessions that are going to be there and
here you have the organization updates
where you can look at each other whoever
is a member of this organization and
their activities which is a nice way of
seeing what any of the of your team
members or your group member is doing
now if you go to this stage you have a
list of different things here forum
courses so the forum is like this right
now I have not written anything there is
no topic created in the forum so this is
blank but once we start with the program
we will have a lot of topics here the
next thing is courses so this is
something again all the coursework that
will be covered during the program is
given here you're free to start and
explore this on your own or you can be
it for us to talk to you about it so
this is something you can go ahead and
do it's all given here
and the next thing that you see is the
progress so this is very interesting
so with our educational platform we do
not need to you know tell you or you do
not need to tell us how much or what you
have done whatever you do will be
recorded here we can actually go to your
profile and see what you are doing what
your progress is what pipelines you're
running what courses are you doing if
you're stuck in any course if you have
passed a quiz if you did not pass a quiz
so everything will be here so next time
you see this probably after a week or so
you will have like a graph going up like
this or going down depending on all of
the activity of the members and you see
already people who are in
this organization and how much they
worked on the education platform how
much they've worked and the server
platform is recorded here
so moving on you have the syllabus so
most of you might have received a
curriculum from our end and if you have
not you're always free to go down to the
syllabus section here and explore all of
these platforms all of these syllabus
and topics and what we will be covering
in the different sessions here so and
the next thing that we go ahead is the
hands-on assignment which again
Rohit spoke to you about now let me talk
a little bit about the registration
process so if you come to their home
section so the first thing that many of
you have done have already registered is
you have gotten the link to this landing
page you have registered here as you see
it has already all of my up signed up to
this page now when you go ahead and meet
the payment you go to the home page and
here you can actually register for
membership if you click on this link you
would be taken to this page so here you
can already see all of the the amount
you stated here the number of days is
expires for the license is valid for
it's given here you can pay buyer this
link so it might be that many of you
cannot pay via the MasterCard or the
debit card that you have and if so we
have other payment methods that we have
sent to you by email but if you can do
it and once you start paying here an
account is automatically created for you
and so this is how you do the payment
and if you always have any problem you
can reach out to me you can have my
email ID and I think most of you have my
phone number as well and I am trying to
interact with everybody but even if I
miss out on someone you can always talk
to us in our forum in our chats you can
talk to our campus ambassadors and you
know go ahead so the next thing that we
have
is the activity tab so here you can see
the activity here so the activity tab
actually shows you the activity of all
the members here so you can see the our
number of members is 2263 so now if you
go down you can see what everyone in the
platform has been exploring and the next
thing you have is the leaderboard so
once you start collecting points so let
me show you a profile here okay so let
me go to my profile here
okay for shine thorn yes shine tone for
anyone who has paid save today or two
three days before we will need some time
to send you the login details and your
account will be activated they activated
before the program is there you do not
have to worry about it I will be
reaching out to you via email or phone
call regarding it but we will be
creating your credential so it just
takes time you just have to be patient
with us regarding that okay okay moving
on so as I was showing you my profile
here so this is how a profile should
look like see you have your member thing
here so it usually is your name or the
email ID you are signed up with when you
come down here you can actually change
everything from the profile section and
you can add all of your social media
links here you can see how many points
you have collected so this is where the
leaderboard comes in so you see darker
right now he's a data scientist with us
from Montenegro and he has collected
over so many points so and we have added
this new feature which shows you you
know how many points you have received
this week so you can see that Bobby has
received run plus 450 points so this is
a good way to see who and how many
people are running the platform area has
got ten more points so you can see as
you can see that irishman here health is
at forty three thousand five sixty
points
Sarah could not share her screen and she
is now at number nine with twenty
thousand eight eighty points this is a
way the more courses you do the more you
interact with us and the more you post
on the forum and on the organization
page you can get a lot more number of
points and you can rise up in the leader
pool and once you go up in the
leaderboard we feature you on our blog
and on our social media pages so like
this is our latest feature it is shined
any coach and this is on our blog and
social media so you can
see what Scheinman is doing so we do
like an interview by email and they post
about the person you can see here at
that point of time when I was writing
this Chandini had collected 14,000 950
points so this is how we create an
interactive community of people and we
try to stay active with all of you and
try to reach out to everyone so I think
that is all about the platform now any
time you have any kind of problem you
can always start and talk to us through
any of these mediums and please try and
update your profiles and let us start
the sessions and now I'm going to stop
sharing my screen so that movie can take
over thank you for this wonderful
introduction and overview
I think the people I think people who
have questions will be reaching out to
you and now we will go to the
presentation where we are going through
the syllabus
so
as we saw as you saw the profile and the
certification and all those things
On January 20th we will learn about
next-generation sequencing data and the
need for pre-processing mapping
quantification and you know concepts
like that so we will be going through
once you learn about the demo pipeline
in the previous session it will be easy
to you for you to understand these
techniques so to see how these methods
are used in real RNA seek studies we
will practice together running such
pipelines because you will also have the
login I will also use my login and we
will run the Python together and we'll
see our analysis using the T bind for
server which is exclusively available
for you this is the T
for server of platform so as you see
this is you know a complex pipeline with
many algorithms so this is one of the
pipelines as I was telling you this is
one of the pipelines and we have like
seven pipelines like this to do
different types of analysis in this
program we will be talking about the
transcriptomics analysis so we will be
doing you know pre-processing
we will be doing mapping to the genome
we will be mapping to the transcripts we
will look at the iso construction then
we will have a you know table of
expression and then we will do this
analysis for for few data steps and
learn a lot about you know how to do
these research so it is very easy to use
because it as I said these pipelines are
color coded so there is specific color
for pre-processing there is a specific
color for you know mapping the specific
color for quantification so that you can
guide so that you can you know guide
through these guidelines and understand
this ease
January 23rd we will be doing a little
bit more often you know advanced
analysis in this session in this session
we will be learning about statistical
analysis using RNA seek data the process
our basic data which is very well
described in transcriptomic to course we
will see how exploring the gene
expression table and understanding its
properties can help us spot you know
technical variations that can have
unwanted effects on our analysis we will
discuss how we can compare group of
samples that represents different you
know conditions and learn about
differential gene expression t-test and
regression all through you know
interactive slides and videos as well as
you know doing the hands-on session on
the server so this is very important on
30th January 2020 after we did like you
know for complete transcriptomics 1 & 2
we would like to know revise this
actually has helped us in the past and
we wanted to make this into a habit that
whatever we learn we just don't you know
keep on going and learning new things
but we also recapitulate and device what
you have what we have done so we will do
an online workshop so in this online
workshop this is a very unique workshop
because it will be for two hours and we
you will be sharing your screen like I
am sharing my screen you will be sharing
your screen and if you have any problem
you know it's like a hands-on online if
you have any problem in understanding
anything will help you in that like you
know well the file there how do I run
the plat for use the platform how do I
use my login any coach question may not
be any basic question to make that be
any advanced question about the
algorithm about the data type that we
have learnt so we will do this on
January 30th and I think it will be at
the same time or maybe a little bit
earlier because it's for two hours so
the time would be rough it would be this
7:30 or 8:30
so that we will tell you once the
program starts after doing all that
analysis I mean all that practice and
getting you know ready we will jump to
the next session about the exploratory
data analysis this is something where
the machine learning you know of machine
learning stuff so oftentimes what
happens is like you know using standard
statistical tests they do not capture
the granularity of expression data so
expression data is big data right to
learn about these methods that can
handle complexity that is typical to
large omics data sets we have to learn
additional methods like dimensionality
reduction you might have heard a lot
about you know TCA principle component
analysis so we've been you know using
PCA quite a lot you know research in our
courses so we will tell you how simple
it is how you can do pca with your data
and understand what actually pca does to
your data it actually reduces the data
reduces the dimensionality and you know
provide you with more critical
information so we will learn how we do
that we will also learn very popular
methods called H clustering and came
interesting these are all machine
learning methods for you know doing
these are for unsupervised machine
learning methods to explore data so we
will be doing exploratory data analysis
using you know a study and hands-on cell
line projects so we will be using the
demo pipelines will show you hands-on
how to do it and we will also do the
theoretical you know understanding of
how these methods work so as I was
telling you that some of the techniques
are easy to use and can be done in Excel
once we like to do the analysis we will
download the result and we will see the
result and then we will open it in Excel
or any other you know table manipulation
software and we will look into the data
but we have got from the platform also
we will do the PCA as I was telling you
that this is a typical PCA graph which
shows like here
you see the data is very close to each
other so it it has low variation right
here the data is expanded like this the
higher variation because this point is
you know far from this point simple like
we're talking about the variation here's
the component components how they
explain the variation we'll talk about
that and you'll understand pc-1 pc2 in
pca and how they work in the next class
that would be on sixth we will be doing
the data mining technique so this is
again very interesting because first you
do the data exploration and then you do
the you know supervised machine learning
methods like how do you mind data as as
you could imagine like in a field where
you know in a mind you know you know
diamond mines you're mining and you're
mining and you're looking for one
diamond maybe so you're you know that's
how we are doing in data mining this
data is so based we are looking for
critical information useful information
that would you know help us explain our
you know problem explain the research
that we are doing so we are trying to
mine data so how we are using machine
learning tools so we will be learning
about decision trees random forests and
how they are you know applied in mushiya
in in understanding of the
transcriptomics data will also learn
about the challenges not only about the
machine learning methods but every
machine learning method is different
from another one and how and how they
perform on different data sets I mean
why we use this machine learning method
why we use that machine learning method
what information those machine learning
machine learning methods are giving is
something that we are we will be going
through in this program so we will be
learning about for example a defined
pattern of expression and how it can be
linked to you know regulatory niche
network so we will be learning about
those in very simple you know by using
simple examples it might look
complex right now but while we will be
having sessions after sessions and
you'll be going to the courses it'll be
really easy to understand how these
patterns can be you know like you can
see here there is you know big graphs
like big line there's a pattern right
here you see this like low low values
this is high values so you can clearly
see a path so we will be working and
discussing those patterns and how to
identify patterns in a big dataset so in
this course this course has a lot of
machine learning methods you know
incorporated in it because we wanted
this program to have a lot of
understanding of you know how these
methods once we learn about the data
mining techniques and explore the
various patterns that seems meaningful
we can train a machine learning model
that will classify new samples you know
it's like after understanding about the
pattern like how if you know if I give
you an example of images of cats and
dogs so if you train a machine with
number of images that represents a cat
and a number of little machine with a
number of pictures that represents a dog
and you ask that machine that camera -
you know predicts a dog or a cat so it's
something like that so what we are
trying to say here is that based on the
data or based on the pattern we will
just you know this is way more complex
and cat and dog because we are talking
about multi-omics our omics data so
we'll be doing discriminant analysis
like l das WL d QD a support vector
machines they are fantastic you know
machine learning methods that helps us
to this helps us in classification will
also look into the data visualization
this will be a you know deep dive into
machine learning and how machine
learning is used for predictive analysis
and once we learn about all this so it's
it's in a flow actually because first we
are talking about the data type and then
we are talking about how these data
types can be you know further studied
using machine learning methods and once
you have get you got some you know
first on you got some critical
information from machine learning
methods what you try to do is to do a
biological interpretation means how the
information that you have received or in
the information that you have mined is
useful to your research so ultimately
that stuff you know that's a goal we try
to connect the data with biology how can
be I'll give you an example how can
these genes isoforms or their expression
level help explain the mechanism of
action explain the process of say
deregulation of vital cellular pathways
or provide indication that a gene of
protein can be considered as a target
for drugs so these are very critical you
know questions in research so we will be
looking at you know team set pathway in
Richmond analysis we will learn to
utilize these and see these pathways so
here if you see that these are like
metabolic pathways you know regulation
of actin cytoskeleton b-cell receptor
signaling pathways these are typical
pathways that are there in immuno
eukaryotes and in many higher organisms
where like you will see in this green
boxes shows you know low expression and
this red box that shows you know high
expression or vice-versa so you will
understand that in a in a particular you
know pathway which genes are
overexpressed in some expressed highly
expressed big genes and have low
expression with genes have medium
expression and then you can see and
compare that these genes these proteins
or these molecules may be causative for
some some you know some some biological
activity that is happening that you
wanted to see so we will be covering
those in this class and the application
of classification in general like you
know these methods are not always used
in small research projects however they
have very important applications in
pharma in biotechnology in research and
development as well as in
application so here is the job aspect as
well why we are learning all this why
why we are doing you know these courses
why we are learning about machine
learning and data driven research
because you know nowadays everything has
changed from you know single experiments
to big data experiments now we are doing
data driven research it's not just in
biology but it's everywhere may that be
you know your your shopping pattern may
that be your travel pattern anywhere now
data is being used that's why this is so
important that that's why it becomes so
important to learn about these and also
another important aspect which is the
precision medicine as you know
personalized medicine so in the coming
days as I was telling you
everyone is collecting data you will
have information about your own genome
so you should be I think everyone should
be aware of their own cells so that you
know they can have the correct you know
correct therapy correct you know dis
they can take direct decision about
their own healthcare that's pretty
important right so it has we will be
talking about you know how these methods
are used in you know biomarker discovery
how these methods are used in drug
repurposing and as I said like for
finding of critical molecule that could
be used for a drug targets so on
February 20th this will be the time
where we will be doing an on-site
workshop so there will be an on-site
workshop which will be maybe a full-day
workshop where we will you know it will
be a free workshop for all MIT
University Kolkata tsuki so in this
workshop it will be an interactive
workshop we will go through mu
transcriptomic data set and learn to
perform the statistics star statistical
and the machine learning data analysis
and the biological interpretation so we
will have brainstorming sessions we will
have on sites you know interaction with
with the students we will also have
group presentations
scientific discussions on different
topics
we will also discuss job opportunities
in bioinformatics as I was telling you
before after this I mean the interesting
part once you all have learned about you
know these techniques and how they are
imply how they're you know about this
application in different domains we will
be you know on 27th of February we will
be starting to work on new
bioinformatics projects so in the
previous program we actually had come up
with several good projects the this
program will include a number of
research projects that you can join as
beeps I was showing you as well ranging
from biomedical to you know agro
biological studies not just by you know
by biomedical but agricultural studies
as well students and faculties from
every newsie Kolkata last year collect
came up with these selected the data
data analysis and together we will
continue to work on the thesis projects
and different projects and learn about
research collaboration during our
three-month program this project will
also help you understand important
research problems as I was telling you
and the ways you can use data analysis
to try to derive meaningful insight so
here I would like to give the stage to
our previous years previous year's
participant of omics logic
transcriptomics introduction to by
informatics and data science program
soham vishwas he's now a fourth-year
student doing b.tech biotechnology to
talk about his experience with by
informatics so through him I stopped by
sharing and I will give the stage to you
yes thank you so hi everyone I'm so hung
from bitching BT sub-8 and I'm happy to
share my check away from mine biotech
with you so first let me show my screen
so I'm like fine biotech so I McMahon
biotech for one year right now and in
previous year I had an opportunity to
work on a project about cancer biomarker
under professor cheeto Pokemon our bio
informatics professor in a mature
University in ovarian cancer so here's a
project title you can see and our
objective was to study the differential
expression in various ovarian cancer
biomarkers and predicting that which
among all these biomarkers are
significant for diagnosis now if you're
wondering that okay so what is cancer
biomarker then let me tell you cancer
biomarker refers to a substance now the
substance can be a molecule or a gene
that indicates the presence of a cancer
in the body so we deal with a variety of
genes or you can say a set of genes as
the cancer biomarkers and we study the
differential expressions of those genes
so meaning like the differential
expression is something that a
particular gene when it is expressed in
various in an entire population in our
various organisms or individuals then it
expressed differentially from one
organism or one individual to another
individual like say like just say the
gene for height so of course someone is
with lesser height and someone is very
tall so like that in cancer - so the
cancer genes are very differentially
expressed so our goal was to predict
which are the most significant biomarker
or the genes among those set of genes so
in this context so now index ponds
extra in order to study DS we
extensively used to the pine biotech
server platform and time biotech was
really helpful for us so what was our
approach so first we corrected it in the
data from various online databases like
fire browse for Cancer Genome Atlas then
we prepared the data so the data must be
prepared for analysis and this was
extensively done by the server platform
already dr. Mohit has showed you and
then we analyzed the data on the
software platform we ran various
pipelines like PCA and Dec etcetera
etcetera so of course when we will study
about on this course so you will be
studied a lot about those pipelines and
how to run those pipelines and lastly we
biologically interpreted those data so
you can just take a look so this is the
problem statement that we figured out
and then okay this is the data
collection procedures so I am NOT going
to in details in this because ok we are
running out of time so just take a look
now this is the data preparation and of
course these are data preparation you
will be trained throughout this course
and here the data analysis and these are
the pipelines so this is particularly a
pipeline that was very useful for our
analysis and this also and this is the
ultimate biological discussions or the
biological interpretations that we had
so so therefore the project was very
exciting it so it was about ovarian
cancer and of course you know that the
cancer is a very critical disease in
nowadays so
yes we had a great exposure to the
hands-on practical set as well as we can
cultivate our knowledge throughout our
hands-on practicals by exploring the
software platforms and also so about and
also after that completing dates in our
project I was I am now doing another
project under a book though and it is
about leprosy so we had two bacteria one
is Mycobacterium leprae and another is
Mycobacterium leprae mitosis and we are
studying the epidemiology of these are
two bacterias so therefore the project
the these projects are very much
exciting for us and we are doing from
since last one year so here I am
stopping my screen shot and thank you
thank you love the mood for these media
shows thank you sure thank you for this
wonderful presentation and we do have
dr. claw Buddha here with us so I will
like to if possible if you can talk I
would like to give them the stage to
talk about the project and his
experience Elizabeth doctor Prabhu's are
you there
so dr. Prabhu brand of potato blotto
will be helping us in taking you the
process will be will be also your guide
to MIT University and they'll also be
your guide here along with me and Joe
Callahan who is our you know community
who is our faculty at Pine biotech so we
have a lot of people to guide you
through this whole you know experience
so let me again share the present and
share the presentation and show you the
the last few slides which will which we
will talk about the
this with us
you
you
so as Salam described about biomarker
project cancer ovarian pods the project
and leprosy project we also were working
on tomato projects about the fruit
ripening project and sarra who who she
was unable to talk but she was very much
excited to talk about her tardigrades
project so it was again a very
interesting project you can always reach
out to her in MIT and you know discuss
and talk more about her research so
ultimately you know the goal is like
many of our past participants
participants of bioinformatics for
India's this program should get an
opportunity to present their analysis in
front of their classmates and peers like
your classmates and peers or even
conference poster sessions paper
sessions and workshops so that is the
ultimate goal so we will be trying to
conduct one of these sessions in our
upcoming you know workshop but also you
know the projects that we are working on
as a lot of value to your CV because
these are the projects that we you know
usually people discuss in the interviews
these are the projects that will you
know stand out in your application for
you know masters or PhD or our jobs so I
think it is very important and very
critical to you know do these and do the
complete learning and maybe finish the
project and do a poster session it's not
that difficult and we've been you know
doing it with everyone who comes up with
like basic and new knowledge we try to
learn from the beginning start from the
scratch and then try to build into
something which is of high value see
here in Louisiana we work on different
projects and also in MIT we have worked
on fantastic projects so I think it will
be a great experience for you know
researchers students especially students
to get exposure to such cutting-edge
research and also to expose themselves
in the research scientific community as
I was telling you like you know fine
biotech sporadic web
Oh informatics programs have been highly
recommended by our previous participant
so you can go and talk to your you know
POS you can go and see the you know
reviews in our platforms together we are
trying to build a you know vibrant
community by informatics community that
works together to you know address
cutting-edge research problems using bio
informatics so during this program we
would like to welcome you to your arm we
would like to welcome you join us for
this exciting program by registering
with us and you can always talk to beep
sha and you can talk to me and talk to
participants on the previous
participants as well as the campus
ambassadors to learn more but it would
be great to have you with us and you
know do this together go through this
journey and learn more about by
informatics and cutting-edge research
which is which would be a prerequisite
for the future so I would like to stop
here we are already above our time but
we'll be happy to you know answer all
the queries that you have so I will stop
here and ask you for your questions and
and then we can conclude the session
you
so you can write in the chat box if you
have any question and beep here if you
want to say something yes
so anyone if you want to ask a question
you can unmute yourself and ask and for
the registration or any other thing
please reach out to me by whatsapp or
email I've put it in the chat and I'm
also adding the organization page link
for all of our members have already
become part of the program so you can go
ahead and explore the things that I've
shown you so Shin Genie is asking a
question when we start the course is
like transcriptomics 1 what if you yes
engineer I think bitshares already told
you this in during the presentation that
you can start it right away
and we can help you with that and if you
have any problems because these courses
are already you know available are
available and if you have any problem in
accessing these courses let us know so
you can start with the course but we
will be covering them as I showed you
during the whole presentation that we'll
be covering them one by one in a process
in a slow way you understand you know we
will guide you through this whole
process so even if you go through it we
will again you know go through it with
you and if you have more questions that
time it would be really nice ok you're
welcome Shin Gini thank you Mohit for
answering that and also for anyone who
is going to start say for the first time
it is always recommended as I said again
and I'm repeating myself that start with
introduction to buying for matrix that
really gives you an overview of
everything and then you can choose to go
ahead with any of the other coursework
you have but doing that will give you an
understanding
okay so Dipendra has a question what if
you would like to answer that yeah
Jitendra it's a valid question so
usually in this program we start with an
educational data set which is already
published and we explore what they have
already turned because we are trying to
validate and we are trying to do and
learn the basics first and then we go
into you know as I said new projects yes
we start working on on your own data
maybe or your own idea so you have to
come up with idea and publishing of
paper you know publishing publishing a
research paper takes awhile but yeah of
course I mean why not I mean that's the
purpose right that's what I said like
doing a good analysis if you get great
results if you get good results then
definitely you can publish that go to
conferences you know validates with talk
to scientists have more ideas and of
course publish that paper
you
yeah you're welcome
you
you
as I said you know this job
opportunities we will be discussing this
in more detail during this program but
if you see like we keep on we will be
adding you to our LinkedIn group where
we keep on posting about job
opportunities related to this type of
data analysis by informatics analysis
yes there will be many job opportunities
but as I said like job opportunities
varies from you know location varies
from expertise so first we should try to
you know get skilled get you know that
exposure to understand a research
problem to understand you know what is
actually happening in this world of
research in this current world of
research once you learn that once you
understand that I don't think there is
any stopping you from getting a good job
because there is a lot of opportunity
with you know data analysis big data
analysis by informatics especially in
this NGS data analysis domain there are
a lot of opportunities that I can tell
you we don't provide any you know job
opportunities by ourselves but we can
always guide you towards the right
opportunity
you're welcome Shenton so if we
don't have any more questions I think we
can end the session here and I will be
hoping to see you all on Monday the
course includes learning in Python or R
so yeah it's a very good question again
so many of the data analysis part that
we talked about the first we do the
analysis from you know big data files
like pasta files
BAM Sam pies from there we understand
the table of expression from there we
get you know the platform gives us you
know output in our script so we also
have courses on our how to utilize our
using our platform how to increase how
to you know change the visualization and
make it more publishable or season
tables so we we can you can always work
with us to learn more about our and
specific packages python is more
programming intensive so our courses are
built for biologists and we are trying
to you know teach everyone about these
data types so getting into a coding
language would be out of the scope of
this program but we will have more you
know upcoming courses where it will be
more you know programming intensive in
the future
no I don't think you need to learn art
from scratch anyone does not need to
learn in about anything about our right
now so we will be first focusing on the
data type like the NGS technology which
is very important to learn and then we
will learn about the data analysis and
during that analysis part we will be
using some art packages and that is
again very easy to use we will be
guiding you how to use it there's also a
tutorial actually which is like you can
just see that and you know emulate in
your PC so also if you have any problems
during that time you will be helping you
with that so I don't think you need any
extra knowledge and additional knowledge
to learn for this program but you know
if you're interested in learning art
there is no harm yes we have machine
learning section which which has all the
algorithms and all the essential data
types to handles so yes the server will
have server we will do the machine
learning part
you
you
you
alright this if you are learning about
methylation by NGS so I said about the
epigenetic data type so we will see I
think it's pretty important to
understand the transcriptomic data for
to learn about the platform and then you
can once you're comfortable with the
platform once you start exploring the
NGS the RNA seek data you'll be able to
explore the difference with different
other you know pipelines where you can
you know learn about the methylation by
NGS and will also be coming up with of
course epigenetic course which will
address the exact same thing as you said
the telogen by India so we'll be telling
you more about that course in future but
right now this program will be in this
program we'll be talking about the
expression data and I think which which
is pretty much critical super rajesh
thus so high do we have to build the
machine learning models ourselves we
will be doing it together like as I said
like these classes these sessions will
be interactive and we'll have a
practical you know exercise so the
practical exercise the way it works is
that is that that we will be doing it
together you will be also accessing the
platform I will be also including the
platform and we'll be doing the machine
learning models together with before
machine learning models we will do the
data exploration and we'll understand
how these machine learning methods help
us to get to the right answers for that
we will be building classifier at the
end using you know data mining and after
that class we will be looking at the
biological interpretation as well as I
covered during the program so yes in
this program
you will talk about metagenomics no we
have just finished one program on
metagenomics so we will not be talking
much about metagenomics but a general
overview of Atomics but we have already
good coaches on metagenomics available
on the platform you are free to explore
those metagenomic courses and if you
have any questions and if you have a
research problem then you can get back
to us and we can discuss that as well
the two body party hi so will discover
both yes this will cover both short and
long grades in so we will be covering
all the types we will be doing fpkm ask
and all those parameters will be
understanding those so anything
associated with char you know
transcriptomics data will be learning
about those features and how to do the
data analysis
you
you know Thank You Bo for sharing that
link and you're welcome party for
metagenomics yes
you
you're welcome
every
thank you for joining today's meeting
and it was great to have you here and if
you have any questions please reach out
to us and even if you don't want to join
if you don't if you can join the program
please explore our platform it's a it
gives you a good learning experience I
can guarantee you that so please take up
the free poses if not and let us know I
mean we are we are really eager to learn
about the feedback about how you like
the coaches or how you want to suggest
so thank you again for everyone for
attending today's meeting and we will
also be sending out the recording of
this meeting so if you have missed
anything and if you want to you know
reassured and if you want to go back and
learn about each session you can do that
thank you again and also during the
session as we said that we will keep on
you know recording our sessions and then
keep on sending them to our participants
so that they can do it at their own time
at their own you know pace because
sometimes we get dizzy in different
tasks and then we can take our time
because this is an online platform all
you need is your laptop or maybe mobile
phone so thank you again for joining
today
and hope to see you soon